former front office executive for the
eagles and browns and one of our
favorites to ask questions to about
what's going on in the business of the
NFL Joe banner back here on the Rich
Eisen show I'll give you the floor on
the DeAndre Hopkins and for David
Johnson trade what you think of when the
Texans and the Cardinals pulled that one
off Joe I think I've said this about the
last four moves they've made I just
don't really get it I mean they're
they're now in a situation where they
don't have cap Romo they don't have
draft picks and so what happens is you
lose one of the top players one of the
top difference makers in the entire game
and you don't even make sure you get the
proper compensation back so I mean I've
been questioning this for a while this
is a reflection of kind of the boobs
they've been the last few years they've
made some short-term decisions that are
allowed them to stay competitive in the
division but not really in the league
and I think this is a you know
predictable and you know they lost in my
mind you know one of the top couple of
players that have played a position that
can potentially make a huge difference
so I mean does does this happen if the
coach and general manager are not one in
the same
do you think I'm a big believer that
there isn't a structure that defines
success in the NFL it's who do you
empower and are they good at what you
give them to do so
I don't think Bill O'Brien has
demonstrated the ability to be good at
making personnel decisions managing the
building of the team managing the cap
and all the other intricacies that go
with it
but I can point the teams that have
general managers that you know we're
respected or recruited heavily to get
the jobs and frankly they've made a lot
of mistakes so I differentiate in this
case I don't think there's any chance
the model is working or will work but I
don't think that's a function of a
structure as much it is you know Bill is
demonstrated ability to at least be a
solid coach and not the ability to be
better at more than that and some guys
I've worked with Andy Reid is you know
for 14 years he could do both and it
wasn't even a challenge so the question
I personally to give that kind of range
of responsibility to interesting
so that maybe there's something out
there's got to be something else at play
here I mean why are too and and and take
on David Johnson's contract there has to
be something that that that certainly
when Stefon Diggs is who's a terrific
younger receiver in his own right but
isn't on the career Canton path so far
like DeAndre Hopkins is eight years in
in DeAndre gives twenty seven right and
and so how does this it just doesn't
compute when Diggs gets a team of four
picks including a first rounder how does
that happen
walk me through that Joe so the only
explanation of course we're guessing the
date they're not going to tell us but
it's reasonable guessing when you have a
cap problem and you have so and a
quarterback about to break the bank at
both positions pencil because he's very
good young and you traded for him
without getting an extension shame on
you
Watson because he's very good and that's
what quarterbacks make it and he's
eligible for an extension then you find
yourself in a position where you have to
move a guy like this now that doesn't
explain why they didn't get anything for
him of the value that we think we should
that's just inexplicable but why they
had to move him but be sitting there
saying listen I'm not coming back in a
camp unless you give me a new deal and
you don't have cap room and you've got
these two guys that you have to sign
then you have to make a move to get rid
of a guy like this now they took on a
decent salary in Johnson but they can
get out of that fairly quickly if they
need to if they read it a deal with
Hopkins they have to increase the one I
have to give him a new signing bonds
they have a new probations and they
can't get out of the deal so easily so I
think the origination of this was that
they couldn't afford to give him a new
contract that he was adamant about
getting it whatever other tensions they
are there there's always that kind of
stuff you get a player of this caliber
you put up with the tension so my theory
is all emanates from this lack of
graphics and the lack of cap room draft
picks can cure cap problems but if you
don't have either you got a big problem
and then you got two guys that have the
hammer to write and Tunsil and
yesin you know if I were advising
console I'd say you know why are you
reporting without a new deal all of the
top players now and we've seen it
already we just saw they would happen
with the Forrest Buckner we saw what
happened with Cleo necklace oh it
happened with Donald we see what
happened with you know Elliot you know
these top players are getting deals
after three or four years you know
you're talking about a top player
playing one of the most important
positions on the team that you just saw
them give up to ones and a two plus
other stuff to get I'm just saying
they're saying I'll come when you give
me a new contract and it will be a
record-breaking contract because he has
all the leverage now and that's what the
top players are doing some of them are
doing it quietly trying to get deals
done with their team some of we've seen
be much more aggressive and public about
it but that's what they do and you know
same with Watson I mean I if I'm
representing a top-tier quarterback
right now I'm not going past the third
year of that contract before I'm getting
him a new one and he's been hurt so it's
even more important for him Joe Banner
longtime NFL executive joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show this is maybe
your fourth fifth appearance on the show
love having you on it seems it's a
tradition when you and I talk to talk
about the Cowboys paying top dollar at
the top of the market and here we are
with a Marty Cooper fresh off a
five-year 100 million dollar deal I
don't know how much of that is real or
what I give you the floor on paying dak
33 million per it very least for Vista
this year this deal with Cooper and Zeke
in year two of a very expensive deal
that's that's what you're paying your
triplets are the Cowboys set up for
success in your estimation Joe they're
gonna benefit from the CBA B being done
and a jump in the cap but you know I had
a meeting with common policy when Jeff
and I took over the team that was
something that affected how we ran the
Eagles for a long time coming had a
really great way of explaining cap
dollars he referred to them as poker
chips and he said when I sit down at a
poker table I'm probably gonna win about
as many hands as a guy next so the only
thing that differentiate us did I bet
more on the
right hands for the wrong hands so you
want to stretch your poker chips to make
as many bets as you possibly can and if
you're waiting to the last minute of
handing a player all of the leverage
you're paying players at it with you
know 1517 and plays that are worth 17 or
18 20 and quarterbacks that are worth 32
32 33 and 35 you just you just develop
ten million dollars fewer poker chips to
place bets and try to make sure that you
don't win any more often than the guy
next to you but you're actually making
more money because you place the bets on
the right hands and I've thought about
the cap on all the years I managed it
from that perspective from the minute he
said it and that's where the Cowboys are
bad they could be getting more for their
money that's all I mean by that and they
could do it by finding the exact same
players earlier what do you think's
gonna happen with Jack play on the tag
come up with a long-term agreement what
do you think is gonna happen on that
yeah I think I said in your show a year
ago for the first time is he lining up
to be the next Kirk Cousins I don't
think he was a year ago I think it was
an opportunity to do a deal you know we
don't know that we won't know that
diddly see how he behaves but you know
the two tags right now produced probably
a higher average than anybody would give
him there's a small risk but it's really
small and then he's a young accomplished
quarterback free for any team in the
league to bid on and you know Kirk
Cousins wasn't the best quarterback to
come along but he if you factor in
length and structure and guarantees may
have gotten close to the best
quarterback contract anybody's seen well
it looks like if he plays everything out
with his extension he'll have seven
straight years of guaranteed money like
a baseball player yes right and yes sign
a new contract that will be three or
four years long which will be fully
guaranteed so he could have an entire
career of at least at the time he signed
it fully guaranteed contracts and we
haven't seen that so you know that could
be a strategy or he could just be
waiting I would be really shocked if 33
million ish wasn't a good enough average
to get it done I heard a year ago that
the problems were around structure as
opposed to average and maybe that's
still persisting because you know you
can say 105 million dollars in
guarantees but when the guarantees kick
in how much is guaranteed on signing
huge difference and he has the leverage
to make sure those numbers are what he
wants them to be now Joe banner here on
the Rich Eisen show long time front
office executive for the Eagles and
Browns and more so read the tea leaves
about what's happening in Carolina and
cam for me when you're seeing what
you're seeing with Carolina bringing in
a new coach and giving him a ton of
years and bringing in the young
coordinator of the moment and Joe Brady
and the owner giving them a whole bunch
of license to do what they wish and cam
saying on Instagram today a you know I
never asked for the trade that I've been
supposedly given permission to seek you
manipulated the narrative and act like I
wanted this you forced me into this is
what he tweeted out or he Instagram
doubt read the that was a response to
the Panthers instagramming out we've
given Cam Newton permission to seek a
trade one of the tea leaves here well
they're really straightforward at this
point and I'm not surprised I mean I've
been a big proponent some publicly and a
lot privately with people to ask me but
head coaches the last couple of years
that Matt rule was the top available guy
out there you mean he went 1 in 11 in
the first year at Baylor and team called
me and asked me who would you hire and I
said Matt rule and they told me I was
out of my mind and Matt and Bridgewater
is what I would predict you'd see a very
smart guy talking about Bridgewater
who's very accurate but with some other
limitations so he may turn out to be the
guy or not but that's what fits Matt
he's going to focus on execution he's
going to surround people where the
talent he's gonna build two lines that
can dominate a football game he's going
to be sound strategically and you can
love cam I recognize that isn't the
description of cam but it is the
description of Bridgewater so this
doesn't surprise me at all it seemed
like there was kind of peace here and I
kept cautioning people you know wait a
little longer before you declare you
know what the outcome is there
I like Bridgewater you know we have to
see if you can stay healthy we have to
see if he can rise they take his game up
to a little bit higher level but I think
you're going to see this is the type of
player he's going to build the team with
a really committed guy a really
competitive
working guy and prioritize that over you
know maybe the guy that's the biggest
stud or maybe harder to manage at least
until he's established a culture that
he's comfortable with so what if cam
says screw it I'm not seeking a trade
you know I mean what happens I can't
because they'll have to they'll have to
cut them right I mean they'll have to
just just let them go and then he'll be
a free agent to do whatever the heck he
wants the problem is as many teams might
have their jobs filled by then what are
Cam's options here and where do you
think might be the best fit for him Joe
so if I'm Kim's agent I'm going back in
and say listen we don't want to seek a
trade can you release us so that there's
still at least some empty seats on the
bus here and that's the only way you can
get any control over the situation of
course what will really happen is the
agent may calls with or without
permission probably has already felt out
the market anticipating at least this
was a possibility and has an idea you
know what's available and you know
what's not available so who knows it
only takes one team and obviously he's
had tremendous success he's also had
kind of a period here where he's had
trouble staying healthy and the last
position you want to be sweating out
whether a guy can stay healthy or not is
your quarterback but listen Carolina's
going to do that with with Bridgewater
so in the situation's right somebody
does that but if I were the agent I
would say Ken instead of seeking the
trade can just release us and you know
that would be a tough call for them for
the pimp it's on one hand they think
they have a valuable asset and they want
to get something for it on the other
hand they don't want to have all this
discord early and I knew coach's tenure
and looking side eyes from some of the
players on the team and say you know
what are you doing here and may want to
just kind of clean it up and move on to
the next thing I know and he has been as
advertised entertaining an iconic I know
when he said that at his first combine
people were like boy he's full of it but
I mean he's he's done his duty for for
the Carolina Panthers perhaps they they
should do that it may perhaps where
Brady does not go might be the option
for cam right Los Angeles the Chargers
would have to say hey we got Cam Newton
here would be somewhat significant and
and serving what what no doubt would
fill their need to let the Los Angeles
market know that they've got a big-name
player Tampa I don't know I mean you
want to talk about no risk yet no
biscuit that's Cam Newton right so maybe
that would be a fit yeah yeah I'm not a
huge Winston fan but I think if you had
a choice between Winston and Newton you
know you may be challenged between
somebody a little more upside to me
that's Newton and somebody is Winston
who you're familiar with and has been
able to stay healthy and at least you've
got a year in the system but that would
be a difficult choice if you actually
you know ended up in that situation you
know it's it's not gonna be a great
market for cam it's just not that many
seats available some teams kind of
expecting that I draft somebody in the
top ten or fifteen picks is not really
in the quarterback market which sounds
odd and health has been an issue here
the last couple of years and they say
that one position you really hope that
peace of mind if possible you'll trade
it off for talent but if possible is a
quarterback position where it's an
exception that he gets hurt as opposed
to something that's almost predictable
in the minute I have left what do you
think Bella checks Plan B is now that
Brady's moving on what do you think
those players are and the reason that
you know Chicago couldn't get him out
there was because he wanted to see what
happened to England I have no idea if
those rumors right that makes sense to
me because the one thing I'm sure of is
he will focus on somebody that can
execute his offense who he perceives to
be kind of smart in a instinctive
intuitive sense somebody that will you
know bring absolutely no you know
baggage with them whatsoever
strong in a learning curve strong leader
in the locker room that does kind of
sound like dolphin to me not that he's
the long-term answer necessarily but at
least fits what they've historically
drafted and obviously what they had in
Brady just a smart sound guy you know I
build more than anybody thinks their
schemes and their systems and their
surroundings can win he just doesn't
want somebody to drag it backwards Joe
love the time love our chats always will
be calling again really soon because
things are moving very very fast and
stay home stay safe stay healthy you
take care of you
great being on right back agent Joe
banner at you a banner 13 follow him on
Twitter is a great follow